salut et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
vidéo sur les illusions d'optique mais
attention pas les illusions d'optique
que vous avez l'habitude de voir depuis
des années sur internet non les
nouvelles illusions d'optique
on pourrait même les qualifiés d'
artistique petite interruption pour vous
rappeler que la tournée du spectacle
continue mais que je vais venir le
rejouer à paris au théâtre de la tour
eiffel le 25 26 27 et 28 avril vous avez
devient dans la description et les dates
de tournée continue avec bientôt vias
alba la vase jouer des tours ya trop de
dettes qui sont sortis dont trois villes
en belgique et ils vivent en suisse
voilà vous allez le lien dans la
description
je vous attends sur scène bon je suis
fasciné par ça et je sais que vous aussi
tout le monde est fasciné par ce genre
d'illusions qui trompe notre esprit
j'avais fait une vidéo sur des illusions
d'optique plutôt récente et méconnu avec
fa rhodes le l'année dernière je crois
vous avez le lien au dessus de moi et
dans la description
mais là on va rencontrer un artiste
plasticien qui s'appelle gérard bannière
son nom d'artiste et bannir tout court
à la base c'est un homme illusionniste
mais aussi un créateur d'illusions à
créateur de texte il a énormément co
écrit pour les passages télévisés de
d'eric antoine voilà c'est lui alors là
forcément vous connaissez ce magicien et
bien lui et derrière ses passages télé
débat clair il a une phrase il dit
toujours qu'on s'a de penser trop tôt de
réfléchir trop tôt et c'est comme ça
qu'il a réussi à modifier des tours de
magie aller plus loin dans des textes et
il ya quelques années il a rencontré la
plastique donc peinture sculpture etc
il a mis de l'illusion là dedans et ça
donne quelque chose d'incroyable basée
sur l'art et les illusions d'optique
loïc génériques
récemment l'acteur faisait partie d'une
expo dans une galerie qui était pas très
loin de chez moi j'ai profité pour y
aller et vont lui demander comment il
était passé de la magie traditionnelle
la magie pour bluffer les gens devant un
public sur une scène à l'art et l'art
plastique en injectant l'illusionniste
qu'est ce qui fait qu'à un moment donné
on prend sept ans jean que là c'est le
hasard
donc je travaillais sur les carrés
magiques mais en tant que magicien et
puis je me suis dit mais qu'on met
toujours des noms des chiffres dans ce
carré magique
on peut peut-être mettre autre chose
pour les j'ai fait j'ai mis des valeurs
numériques des couleurs donc c'est des
chiffres
j'ai remplacé par la couleur et en fait
par hasard
d'après ce qu'on m'a dit que j'avais
créé le premier carré magique de
l'histoire de la peinture et des maths
avec le des additions de couleurs le cas
est magique c'est un truc qui me
passionne j'avais parlé dans une
conférence c'est en fait un carré de 4 4
sur 4 càs traditionnellement à
l'intérieur desquels on met des nombres
ou des chiffes pas forcément consécutif
mais tous différents et le but du jeu
c'est que la somme de chaque ligne et de
chaque colonne sont identiques un seul
et même résultat c'est un truc qu'on se
marre bien quoi effectivement bac nerfs
il ya quelques années avait déjà
commencé à explorer savoir ce qu'on
pouvait en faire du carré magique
différemment avec des couleurs avec des
éléments du tableau périodique ce genre
de choses là et en fait à chaque fois
c'est rationaliser par un chiffre et si
on additionne à chaque fois sa garde la
propriété d'un tableau magique
c'était effectivement un premier pas
vers une utilisation différente de
quelque chose qui était pas vraiment
d'illusions mais on va dire la
nourriture pour l'esprit
ah oui c'est une chaîne ont nourri notre
esprit il y a beaucoup de style
d'illusions d'optiques celles qui sont
dures à interpréter ça on voit une image
ou une autre ou alors on peut voir
quelque chose bougeait dans un sens ou
dans l'autre
il ya aussi celles qui donnent un
problème de proportions un problème de
couleur
il ya aussi celles qui donnent
l'illusion de bouger alors que ce sont
des images fixes comme celle ci à celle
ci aussi la fameuse image des serpents
voilà ça c'est très très connu ça a été
déclinée sous plein de formes comme çà
comme çà comme çà comme çà attention ça
va vous faire mal à la tête
et alors comment bac nerfs a pu prendre
ce principe pour amener ça dans l'art et
bien c'est lui qui va nous montrer sur
l'une de ces heures là c'est quoi
alors celle cesser ça fait partie de la
série éloge du mouvement j'en ai
l'impression que la partie centrale
étant en rotation et le bout j'avais pas
fixe elle est instable
j'ai fait ça pour répondre à une phrase
de salvador dali qui disait le moins
qu'on puisse demander le statut c'est
qu'elle ne bouge pas d'accord mais chez
joly on peut pas faire bouger le statut
quoique on pourrait mais on peut donner
l'illusion qu'elle bouge la grande
question c'est pourquoi c'est instable
pourquoi on voit ce buste de la bouger
même à la caméra ça marchait même loïc
ça lui faisait mal au crâne
alors tout simplement parce que notre
cerveau n'arrive pas à interpréter
l'ensemble déjà l'image est relativement
grande mais même si elle était petite
faut savoir que notre cerveau en
permanence il recompose une image
globale parce que nos yeux bougent en
permanence ils prennent des trucs et
comme ils détectent des lignes il
détecte une cohérence avec les blancs
noirs blancs noirs blancs noirs et il a
envie que tout soit bien alignés voilà
notre cerveau de toute manière il aime
bien quand c'est carrie quoi quand ça
fonctionne et il a tendance à nous
mentir donc ils comblent un peu les
trous et il nous donne une certaine
réalité
sauf que les blancs noirs s'inverse à un
moment donné il doit recomposer avec
cette information en permanence en
oubliant l'autre et donc ça ça crée une
instabilité en fait dans la composition
interne de notre image évidemment le
tableau bouge pas pour de vrai et donc
c'est notre composition mental de
l'ensemble qui fait que ça braie une
fake et ça c'est complètement ouf je
vous disais il ya aussi les illusions
d'optique y sont basés sur des jeux de
couleurs il en a créé une banque n'est
requis un peu incroyable je vais vous la
faire voir dans quelques secondes
mais ça joue sur les couleurs et
pourtant c'est que en noir et blanc
regarder ça et nous de notre côté on est
en train de voir une autre toile
alors là c'est encore un autre procédé
tu vas nous en parler mais qui me fait
froncer les sourcils comme si c'était
blues
ta famille de laide à l'intérieur non
alors c'est que ça tough s'appelle luxe
on a l'impression qu'il ya une ampoule
derrière il ya quelque chose qu'il est
clair au centre et parfois on a du mal à
la regarder j'ai une anticipation de
sensation de douleur moi qui ait les
yeux sensibles mais ça sert
on a envie se plisser les yeux parce que
ça ça finit par faire mal aux yeux alors
pourquoi ça fonctionne pourquoi on a
l'impression qu'il ya un spot derrière
et que nous dans la réalité on est
obligé de front c'est un peu les yeux
quand on le regarde et c'est pas parce
qu'il y avait des fenêtres derrière un
autre endroit ça nous aurait fait le
même effet exactement pareil en fait
l'environnement qui englobe la couleur
va nous donner une interprétation un peu
différente de cette couleur en clair
comme au fur et à mesure notre cerveau
crois que tout est noir c'est ce qu'il
interprète au départ même ce qui est
devenu gris ou quasiment blanc ils
l'interprètent comme du noir
du coup il se dit leblanc est plus blanc
que leblanc ok alors que le blanc du
centre du tableau
c'est exactement le même que les
losanges qu'il ya dans les angles du
tableau donc on a une montée en
puissance c'est notre cortex cérébral
qui fait cette anticipation là à notre
place à la base pour qu'on puisse nous
anticiper les choses mais là il se
trompe complètement jusqu'au point
d'avoir l'impression qu'à une source
lumineuse à l'intérieur et qui nous
éclairent beaucoup trop c'est exactement
ce principe là qui avait tant défrayé
internet à l'époque avec la fameuse robe
que certains voiliers bleu et noir et
d'autres qui la voyaient un petit peu or
un petit peu doré en fait c'était à
cause de l'interprétation qui faisait le
cerveau à l'extérieur c'est à dire
certaines personnes pensent et
inconsciemment c'est leur cerveau qui
décide à leur place que les robes
étaient éclairés par une source
lumineuse artificiel
donc il interpréter la robe comme étant
bleu et noir et ceux qui pensaient que
la robe et en extérieur alors le cerveau
faisait sa propre balance des couleurs
et donc décidé que c'était du jaune
alors que évidemment si on prenait un
outil graphique comme photoshop on avait
toujours la même nuancé le même code de
couleurs mais notre interprétation
changé que c'est évidemment le cas pour
des illusions comme ça ou comme ça ou
encore comme ça les deux couleurs que
vous voyez sont exactement les mêmes et
comme l'environnement autour a changé on
a l'impression que c'est puis la même
couleur à l'intérieur
alors il ya des illusions encore plus
particulière c'est celle qui nécessite
la comparaison un petit peu comme celle
ci vous voyez les deux cercles bon vous
savez ce que je vais vous dire les deux
cercles du centre font exactement la
même taille mais l'environnement autour
nous fait croire que celui qui a entouré
par les petits cercles est beaucoup plus
gros que celui qui est entouré par les
gros cercle évidemment non en partant de
ce principe et surtout en explorant
d'autres principes également bat maire
est allé plus loin avec celui des deux
est de regarder
alors d'abord elle s'appelle illusion
illusion avec az
ok donc on voit deux aides az rouge et
un z de rose dumas qui paraît plus grand
claude on est tous d'accord pour dire
que le rose est beaucoup plus grand que
le rouge
et là on sent qu'il va devenir les
phrases très agaçante je vais le laisser
tout seul vous allez pouvoir bien voir
ça en fait ils ont exactement les deux
aides ont les mêmes dimensions
c'est à dire que s'il y avait un petit
bonhomme qui marchait comme ça il
parcourait la même distance ici que
cette distance là c'est terrible on n'a
pas envie de te voir gérard on n'est pas
d'accord est pourtant c'est vrai
pourtant c'est vrai chaque z est composé
de trois segments
donc on a six segments tout et ses six
segments sont tous identiques les uns
aux autres si on prend les trois
segments du z de rose on peut
reconstituer le z rouge n'a pas besoin
en fait du créateur des lèvres pour
apprendre le processeur là on rentre
dans le cadre ce qui s'appelle la magie
nouvelle où le magicien a pas deux ans
et présent exactement
l'illusion la toile osa question allait
continuer dans la réponse alors ça c'est
fou c'est à dire que effectivement comme
disait bac nerfs c'est une illusion qui
marche tout seul ses terres en se met
devant le tableau il n'y a pas de
consignes mais on comprend en fait que à
tous les coups ce sont les mêmes mais on
comprend pas pourquoi ce serait les
mêmes et effectivement la réponse est
déjà dans le tableau
au tout début quand bak terre me dit ce
sont les mêmes jeudi mais n'ont
évidemment si je prends mon maître le
centre du premier n est pas le même
centre que le deuxième est donc c'est
pas possible
mais effectivement c'est que il n'a pas
remis les proportions exactement au même
endroit pourtant il ya exactement la
même surface de peinture utilisée dans
les deux aides c'est juste que ça a été
décalé un tout petit peu c'est à dire
que au lieu d'être mis comme ça il les a
pris et les amis au dessus et en dessous
de la barre centrale est juste ça ça
arrive à nous rendre dingue on est
persuadé que quand même celui du bas est
quand même beaucoup plus grand eh bien
non comme vous pouvez le voir
actuellement sur cette petite animation
faite par loïc bravo loïc son instagram
et dans la description il
publie rien tu publies rien loïc est ce
que vous connaissez la grille d'hermann
c'est la grille original c'est celle que
voici vous avez l'impression de voir des
tâches qui apparaissent à chaque
intersection voilà c'est une illusion
d'optique très connus bancaire s'est
amusé un petit peu avec ce principe là
et en a fait quelque chose qu'il a
déclinée sous plein d'autres couleurs
regardez il ya quelque chose d'assez
surprenant et je me suis dit si ces
taches apparaissent elle doit gêner à la
vue et donc je vais mettre des points
blancs à différents endroits à ceux qui
sont ici et peut-être que ça va s'gêner
peut-être qu'on ne les verra pas parce
qu'il ya quelque chose qui va prendre
qui va prendre leur place dans les faits
donc ça ça fonctionne en ajoutant ces
points blancs sur la grille sur la
grille derna donc après moi je les fais
avec différentes couleurs pour voir si
ça fonctionnait et puis par hasard j'ai
pris ces deux couleurs là et là on voit
les 11 points blancs en même temps alors
que dans les trois autres on est dans
l'impossibilité de les voir tous en même
temps
moi je n'arrive pas à avoir plus de deux
en même temps même quand je là je me
suis dit je vais l'avoir ici je vais
mettre mon regard semble de ces trois
points comme ça je vais les voir en même
temps et en fait ce qui se passe c'est
pire c'est que si si je bouge pas les
trois points disparaissent enfin j'en
vois 0 après là c'est quand même génial
c'est toujours basé sur l'environnement
c'est-à-dire l'environnement
colorimétrique mais aussi sur la
géométrie avec le principe d'hermann qui
fait que parfois on voit très clairement
les ronds blanc et parfois pas du tout
alors que encore une fois à la pipette
on peut vérifier c'est exactement le
même blanc mais que notre cerveau
n'arrive plus à percevoir alors baxter a
fait plein de travaux sur plein de
choses pourraient faire dix vidéos sur
tout ce qu'il a produit tellement il est
prolifique en plus il ya toujours un
petit truc qui fait plaisir à l'esprit
genre celle ci voilà celle ci elle me
plaît beaucoup si vous fixez le centre
tout ce qu'il ya autour va disparaître
ba complètement s'éteindre je trouve ça
très marrant comme principe donc il ya
plein plein de choses à savoir sur lui
c'est un véritable artiste à suivre mais
la question que je me suis posé ses
commandes et galeriste avait pu
s'intéresser et admettre que l'illusion
rentrer comme ça dans l'art et comment
elle parce que ce sont deux galeristes
qui tiennent cette galerie justement ont
pu avoir envie d'exposer sur ce thème là
je trouvais ça intéressant de voir
comment ça pouvait être perçu après par
les professionnels de ce métier quelle
était la volonté derrière et je vous
présente maintenant les
galerie ce2 exit art contemporain qui
nous accueille et qui accueille entre
autres les oeuvres de gérard dans une
exposition thématique alors le titre de
l'expo déjà c'est dans le réflexe de
narcisse après moi si tu peux dans le
reflet des narcisses tout simplement
parce que c'était une des oeuvres qu'on
allait exposer qui est une oeuvre de
olivier diaz zahrat et attrape moi si tu
peux parce que on voulait jouer avec
cette idée de l'illusion de ce que
l'illusion représente la capacité que
notre cerveau à mais je pense que vous
en avez abondamment parlé avec gérard
deux attrapés justement ce qu'il ya
derrière le concept d'illusions c'est
l'idée de jouer réellement avec quelque
part la partie aveugle de notre cerveau
qui est mal à l'aise parfois et qui
tente l'explication scientifique et qui
se dit non il n'y a pas d'explication
scientifique et parfois oui tout
simplement et oyonnax et vous vous avez
vu l'illusion rentrer dans l'arrêt
progressé au point de se dire on va
faire quelque chose autour d'autant que
ça ouais le jeu a déjà été présent dans
des expositions la thématique jeux avec
nos artistes qui ont travaillé
différemment des jeux d'échelles de
perspectives
mais c'est quelque chose qui nous a
toujours toujours plus et c'est vrai que
l'art est là aussi pour pour faire
plaisir pour s'amuser aussi voilà être
un plaisir merci encore à bach nerfs
d'avoir donné de son temps pour faire
cette vidéo est de nous faire découvrir
toutes ces oeuvres merci aussi à la
galerie exit art contemporain de nous
avoir reçus
vous avez les liens vers toutes ces
personnes dans la description si vous
êtes également intéressé par les oeuvres
de gérard vous pouvez contacter la
galerie exit art contemporain et une
dernière chose quand même
ne vous fiez pas aux apparences c'est un
peu ce qu'on peut retenir en fait de
cette expo là mais je vais dire un truc
que j'ai déjà dit dans mes précédentes
vidéos dans celle du million je croise
et c'est pareil ne vous fiez pas aux
vignettes des vidéos ne vous fiez pas au
titre
quand vous aimez quelqu'un ce que
produit quelqu'un en général venez la
chanson vidéo cliquée cinq secondes
dessus parce que peut-être que vous avez
l'illusion que c'est un truc tu peux pas
vous plaît arrêtez avec ça va vous
plaire moi par exemple je suis nul pour
faire les vignettes et trouver les
titres donc n'hésitez pas à regarder les
vidéos quand elles sortent et si ça vous
plaît pas vous coûter au bout de dix
secondes tard à ces 10 secondes investit
donc voilà ne vous fiez pas aux
apparences passe à liker la vidéo si
elle vous a plu à vous abonner si c'est
pas encore fait ça c'est très important
vous verrez aussi les vidéos sortir plus
facilement vous allez bien ici vous avez
la dernière vidéo qui est sorti sur la
chaîne celle ci je pense devrait vous
plaire à l'étang rapport à très bientôt
ciao